welcome to level two linear equations
let's do a problem so 2x plus 3 is equal
to minus 15 so the minus in there to
make it a little bit tougher so the
first thing we want to do whenever we do
any linear equation is we want to get
all of the variable terms on one hand
side of the equation and all the
constant terms on the other side it
doesn't really matter although I tend to
get my variables on the left-hand side
of the equation
well the only thing that my variables
are already already on the left-hand
side of the equation but I have this
plus 3 that I somehow want to move to
the right-hand side of the equation and
the way I can you can put it in quotes
move the 3 is I could subtract 3 from
both sides of this equation and look at
that carefully as to why you think that
works because if I subtract 3 from the
left-hand side clearly this negative 3
that I'm subtracting the original 3 will
cancel out and become 0 and as long as I
do whatever I do on the left hand side
as long as I do it on the right hand
side as well because whatever you do on
on one hand side of the equal side you
have to do on the other then I'm making
a valid operation so this will simplify
to 2 X because the 3s cancel out they
become just 0 equals minus 15 minus 3
well that's minus 18 and now we're just
at a level two level one problem and you
can just multiply both sides of this
equation times the reciprocal on the
coefficient of 2 X I mean you could some
people just say that we're dividing by
two which is essentially what we're
doing I like to always go with the
reciprocal because if this 2 was a
fraction it's easier to think about it
that way but either way you either
multiply by the reciprocal or divide by
the number it's the same thing so 1/2
times 2x well that's just 1x so you get
x equals and then minus 18 over 2 and
minus 18 over 2 well that just equals
minus 9
let's do another problem and actually
well if we wanted to check it we could
say well the original problem was 2x
plus 3 equals minus 15 so we could say 2
x minus 9 plus 3 2 x minus 9 is minus 18
plus 3
well that equal to minus 15 which is
equal to what the original equation said
so we know it's right that's that's the
neat thing about algebra you can always
check your work let's do another problem
I'm going to put some fractions in this
time just to show you that it's it can
get a little bit a little bit hairy so
let's say I had minus 1/2 X plus 3/4 is
equal to 5/6 so we'll do the same thing
first we just want to get this 3/4 out
of the left hand side of the equation
and and and actually if you want to try
working this out yourself you might want
to pause the video and then play it once
you're ready to see how I do it but
anyway let me move forward assuming you
haven't paused it if we want to get rid
of this 3/4 all we do is we subtract 3/4
from both sides of this equation minus
3/4 well the left hand side the 2 3/4
will just cancel and we get minus 1/2 x
equals and then on the right hand side
we just have to do this we have to do
this fraction addition or a fraction
subtraction so the least common multiple
of 6 & 4 is 12 so that's becomes 5 over
6 is 10 over 12 minus 3 over 4 is 9 over
12 so we get minus 1/2 X is equal to is
equal to 1/12 hopefully I didn't make a
mistake over here and if that step
confuse you I went a little fast you
might just want to review the adding and
subtraction of fractions so going back
to where we were so now all we have to
do is well as the coefficient on the X
term is minus 1/2 and this is now a
level-one problem
so to solve for X we just multiply both
sides by the reciprocal of this minus
1/2 X and that's minus 2 over 1 times
minus 1/2 X on that side and then that's
x minus 2 minus 2 over 1 the left-hand
side and you're used to this by now
simplifies to X the right-hand side
becomes minus 2 over 12 and we could
simplify that further to minus 1 over 6
well let's check that just to make sure
we did the right we got it right okay so
let's try to remember that minus 1 over
6 and so the original problem was minus
1/2 X so here we can substitute the
minus 1 over 6 plus 3/4 I just wrote
only the left-hand side of the original
problem so minus 1/2 times minus 1/6
well that's positive 1 over 12 plus 3/4
well that's the same thing as 12 the 1
stays the same plus 9 1 plus 9 is 10
over 12 and that is equal to 5 over 6
which is what our original problem was
our original problem was this this stuff
I wrote later so this 5/6 so the problem
checks out so hopefully you're now ready
to try some level 2 problems on your own
I might add some other example problems
but the only extra step here relative to
level 1 problems is you'll have this
constant term that you need to add or
subtract from both sides of this
equation and essentially turn it into a
level 1 problem
have fun